for two months the gates of a birmingham
primary school have been a battleground
between religion and education between
parents and the school parents who don't
want their children taught about
same-sex relationships for six weeks
mediation between the council's school
and parents has been taking place behind
the scenes but the mediation has stalled
and the mediator feels he has no option
to break his silence to Skye nerves
I can't think of any other way as I'm
talking to you in Skype to try and get
people to as chief prosecutor for
Northwest England
Nazir Afzal tackled some of society's
toughest issues but this recent conflict
over relationships education in his
hometown of Birmingham has angered him
he says staff were at risk and
frequently reduced to tears by hostility
at the school gates I've looked at the
curriculum there is nothing in the
curriculum as LGBT specific there was
nothing about gay sex I have seen people
walking around outside of that school
with stuff that they have downloaded
from the internet suggesting that this
is on the curriculum this is what is
being taught to their children it's a
lie and this is what I'm dealing with
and it in Park Primary School has been
at the heart of the rau over
relationships education the head teacher
previously told Sky News her position
remained unchanged despite parents and
even her own pupils calling for her to
go it would be a massive step backwards
in education to suddenly say we won't
talk about different types of families
anymore because it might upset some
people it's called this school in
Cheshire is teaching the sort of lesson
protesters are campaigning against some
parents argue these four and
five-year-olds are too young to have
this sort of lesson on their curriculum
there are strong feelings on both sides
of this argument how do you reconcile it
in truth
conversation between those most affected
so you've tried that but not have tried
but it but unfortunately because of
these other agents who've been allowed
to get engaged it's not being able to
work it is working as I said the head
teacher has already sat down with 60
parents she needs to sit down with
another three of the 60 parents in order
for that conversation to happen
I want everybody that's involved there
isn't there shouldn't be involved to
back off these people he refers to as
other agents at protesters with no
connection to or children at the school
mister absol claims some simply want to
settle the score and the Trojan horse
scandal in 2014 when Ofsted found
evidence of strict religious practices
imposed in secular schools in Birmingham
II I have seen dozens and dozens of men
invariably outside of that school coming
straight from the mosque for example or
from whatever place of worship who have
no place to be there what the hell are
they doing outside screaming at
five-year-olds what are they doing of
course that's inflaming the situation
and is it down to that element that you
feel mediation has stalled in Birmingham
absolutely this could be fixed in a day
if the head teacher was allowed to
continue her conversation with the
parents
mr. afsal is calling for the government
to step in he says that the conflict
isn't resolved in Birmingham will see
similar conflict in schools up and down
the country when the lessons but for
mandatory next September
Sallie Lockwood Sky News